six-year-old in West Virginia is among
the latest victims of the deadly flu
epidemic it is the first pediatric flu
death in the state in three years West
Virginia's Department of Health
confirmed the death yesterday according
to recent data there have been more than
30 child flu deaths so far this season
that compares to an estimated 21 at this
time last year the virus is now
widespread in 49 states children and
elderly adults are the most vulnerable
to flu complications our dr. tara Narula
is here with how to keep your kids
healthy Tara good morning morning Nora
why are children more at risk we're
talking about all children but in
particular children under five and even
more so children under two why is that
their immune systems are still
developing
they are play in close contact
constantly with each other and they
don't practice the best hygiene they
don't have the best methods of washing
hands etc but I think the bigger issue
is that in this country we know that on
average only 60% of kids are vaccinated
for the flu we also have data that tells
us that 80% of the children historically
that have died from the flu have been
unvaccinated and a recent study that
said you can actually decrease the flu
deaths in 50% by vaccinating children so
what should you do if you think your
child has the flu
well I think you need to call your
doctor you need to speak to them and say
this is what's going on should I bring
my child in to be examined your doctor
can then assess whether they would be a
candidate for antiviral medications you
want to make sure they rest that they're
hydrated and then one thing that we
teach you know I teach my residents and
fellows is you need to be aggressive
about acting quickly so if you start to
see signs of deterioration and parents
need to know warning signs so for
example is the child breathing faster
are they more short of breath do they
look a little bluish are they listless
or lethargic not eating or drinking
these should be signs that prompt
parents to say you know what I need to
take this kid to the ER quickly it's
also frightening because so many people
have gotten a flu shot are still getting
the flu what do you say is there an
explanation about why that happens well
we just we know that the flu virus
changes it changes from the time they
pick the strains to put in the vaccine a
year ago it also changes during the
production even of the vaccine so there
are multiple different strains but we
know that it is still beneficial to get
the vaccine how do you keep it from
spreading some quick tips right so
parents
keep your kids home until their fever
free off medication for 24 hours make
sure you're vaccinated as the parent
your caregivers are vaccinated clean the
utensils and towels don't let kids share
them you want to teach your kids about
hand-washing about using sanitizer not
kissing and hugging each other when
they're sick sneezing into their arm or
coughing into their arm using tissues
lots of great hygiene practices very dr.
Turner ruler thanks